in society do you think that motherhood
is valued more so than fatherhood
jump in let us know
absolutely
um
I can talk on personal experience I'm a
father
myself three kids twin boys and a girl
and I had a father
and the way society's viewing men
like I've previously heard on this show
it's like we're disposable
the way Society has built up women into
the destruction of the nuclear family as
expense it's also been a detriment to
society and
for that very fat we've become less
appreciated and it's the results it
doesn't play out with Society we're
seeing more people coming from single
parent homes end up in prison or seeing
more
bad people in society coming from single
homes so
to its detriment unfortunately we're not
appreciated it's a kind of citric
Society
not appreciate it if you're a terrible
father
you only appreciate if you're a terrible
father you're only not appreciated if
you're a terrible father
there's a there's a variety of elements
that contribute to being incompetent man
at being a father one of them abandoning
your children the other one being there
when you feel like it not when you need
to be
I'm not a father I have no children I
speak like I do honestly I have to be
honest about that and something maybe
comes natural to me but so be I have
children in my family I have my sister
she's married she has children and so on
and I and I have a father I have a
father from the day one so there's
certain elements that contribute to
being a incompetent manner being the
father and these people just the people
in general use those elements and apply
them generically to all men consistently
and that's why Society assumes the men
are incompetent at being fathers and
they value females more that's one of
the main contributing factors so I'm
just to clarify you're saying that
because of the bad fathers they just
assume it's all of them or yeah because
in my experience I I find that there's a
lot of
good Fathers that don't have access to
their children and a lot of times like
women are spiteful and don't give them
access and then they'll call them
deadbeats but they're not really
deadbeats it's just because the women
won't give them access to their kids
they're not part of the equation of
being a competent father right but to me
like
I would say they are because a lot of
times like it's a different perception
when when they're like when the kids are
younger they think their dad's a
deadbeat but he's not and they find out
when they're 25 or 30 yeah 100 yeah I've
Got a Friend personally actually he was
talking about this the other day
and unfortunately he's on the hook for
child support that for uh for a daughter
that he hasn't seen since she was born
he signed away his rights
and when he was in fact forced to to pay
for the chart he tried to connect with
the child
with uh the the young daughter she's now
I believe 15 years old but due to the
poisoning of the mum
why did he sign the raise rights
Young
he I think well I know
in doing so being young naive not really
knowing the consequences of doing so and
thinking you know a lot of guys may well
they make mistakes and take account for
it but in the hope that signing away the
rights because I believe she was a she
she wasn't from this country so one of
the main reasons so she could leave the
country but in essence she left and came
back started claiming and got him on the
hook although he signed away so when he
tried to establish a relationship
uh the poison was already set in in the
young girl's heart so up until now she
he's not been able to see her wow so
yeah you were going to say something
um yeah so I think if you're signing
away your rights as a father at a young
age like it's natural for a mother to
already think like okay he'd he's not
bringing the effort to want to be the
father to this child at that time as you
said like he changed his opinion so he
probably didn't want to like be that
involved in the child's life at the time
so I think as a single mom if you're
then raising the child doing all those
things that that a two-parent household
should really be doing it's natural to
have that toxic feeling yes you
shouldn't say it on the child or portray
it to the child but I think any person
normally sometimes slips up and they
will say things to the children which is
you're saying they're like poisoning the
idea to the child but also I to do with
the first question I don't think that
Society is saying that
um men shouldn't be appreciated I think
Society wants men to be appreciated but
a lot of men aren't doing enough to be
able to be appreciated I think the same
way we have like Mother's Day we have
Father's day but not as many men are
celebrated on Father's Day because not
as many men are playing that role in
Father's Day or
um or playing that role of actually
being a father to their child and a
father doesn't mean someone who's just
okay I'm gonna pay the bills and be a
provider you need to have an emotional
connection do you think that's the
woman's fault or the man's which one
sorry if if there's a father that's not
involved in in the kid's life whose
fault is that
it's the person who doesn't want to be
involved in the child's life wouldn't
you wouldn't you say it's the mom's
fault for picking him because a lot of
times I see women picking guys that have
you know three three kids by three
different women and then being shocked
when he's not a good dad
I think that's definitely can be the
case so I think people do need to choose
their Partners very wisely because at
the end of the day that's who you're
having a child with and you want to
raise your child with but obviously
people have get into situationships
people fall pregnant things happen and a
lot of men change as well when they find
out that a woman's pregnant they can be
the most loving
um man ever he could have loved bom dude
making me did you fall in love with his
potential everything else and we love
bombing what is that it's like we're at
the start of a relationship or you start
talking to a guy and he tells you
everything you want to hear like what
what we were saying before basically men
women fall in love with what they hear
so men know that so they'll tell you
everything that you want to hear because
you'll fall in love with that potential
hoping he'll be that guy useful is that
whose fault is that yeah to fall in love
with what you have I just I don't I
don't really buy it when women say they
don't know I just think it's a load of
crap like you know damn well that you
know damn well that that like the guy
what is who he is they see the million
red flags and they just don't care
I'm sure you've been there as a woman
you've seen red flags and just ignored
them right yeah I've definitely been in
that situation but I think that comes
down to you as a person for me I want to
see the good in people so okay I've seen
some red flags but I also I've seen good
green flags as well and you want to hope
that the green flags will overtake the
red flags yeah but you like red flags I
I don't like red flags anymore trust me
you said but you said any more right
yeah anymore I think it's an immaturity
thing like in red flags liking immature
men it's just when you're immature and
you haven't gone through that
self-growth to realize there's better
but because so many men have red flags
it's hard to find a man who doesn't have
any so you're just trying to find a man
with the least number of friends do you
think that's a little bit sexist like
what if they were here saying that oh
all these women have all these red flags
and it's really hard to find a woman
that doesn't have any red flags
men say that as well I would say by and
large not the same not as much as women
do no because men say women are toxic so
that's the equivalent of saying that do
you really feel like it's equal in
society
that is equal like men and women equally
dogging each other
I think
um
like yeah I think in the UK they they
both dog each other
do you think like like okay so if we if
we're under a mantra of Mana trash men
are dogs men are deadbeats right how
does that play out into fatherhood you
see so when it comes to the man's role
in the household if if we are being told
women are being told and they're telling
their girlfriends that Mena trash men
are dogs men are deadbeats how do you
think that plays out in the way in which
women see men once they have their
children
um so I don't say I'm in a trash I think
some men are trash I wouldn't generalize
that to all men definitely a large
proportion of men I've experienced the
trash I'm not going to talk on other
women's experiences but I think why do
you think that is why do you think that
a large proportion of men that you
personally expecting she likes red flags
I don't like red flags the ones you've
experienced and then before before when
I was immature younger I would go for
guys with red flags that's just due to
what when did you stop would you say
what age are you 24 so when when did you
stop at the start of this year I got
therapy so I I understood why it hasn't
been long yeah it hasn't been long it
hasn't been long no but there's
definitely a difference so I know what I
like now so like about a year around 24
that was yeah okay so if you if you were
picking trash men right and then you got
a trash result right
um a lot of the time that what exactly
what Pearl was saying women pick trash
men get trash results and then say men
are trash and it's like it's not because
men are trash is because you pick trash
men because the pool of men that you're
choosing from are trash do you know what
I mean so that Mantra of men are trash
is because the majority of women are
dealing with trash men because the
majority of men are trash men no so I
think the pool is a large pool of trash
man okay so maybe speak for yourself
maybe the menu I know a lot of Great Men
no I know a lot of great mentors but I
still think the majority are I would say
I would say that's not true I don't
think the majority of them
it actually matters who raised those men
but you don't know who raised them
so the trash
so statistically right as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible